because I one thing I talk about is I  Outsource decision making sort of like I  have a manager um you might have saw him  use in the back and like even my dad  like those are the two people I talk to  about decisions  um and I honestly like trust them with  it because  it's it's like okay if you have to fire  someone in a business a woman's gonna  typically typically be more emotional oh  I don't like their family I don't want  to do it I don't want to fire them like  but a man is just gonna be like he's not  doing the job he's got to go and and I  had to have like that conversation with  my dad at one point he's like you should  have been done this already and it's  kind of like  like that I don't know I just think men  can like make decisions quicker where  like women will drag it out how